Jon Snow was originally supposed to kill the
Night King on Game of Thrones.
Arya Stark killed the Night King in the final
season of Game of Thrones during the battle
for Winterfell,
but according to the cast, it wasn’t always
supposed to go that way.
A few days ago Maisie Williams (an actress
who played Arya Stark) revealed that Kit Harington
(an actor who plays Jon Snow) told her and
everyone else
that he was going to go that way, quoting
Kit
''Someone told me in season 3 that I was going
to kill The Night King.”And this is what
should have happened.
That would have given us a satisfying conclusion
to Jon Snow's story.
That would have fulfilled the long built prophecy
of Jon Snow being the Prince that was promised.
That would have justified Rhaegar and his
obsession with prophecies as well,
especially because creating Jon Snow who Rhaegar
believed would be the Prince that was promised,
it cost Rhaegar his own life as well as the
lives of his both wives,
Lyanna who died giving birth to Jon and Rhaegar’s
first wife Ellia.
Children Rhaegar had with Elia were also brutally
killed.
The Mad King died as well as 10s of thousands
of soldiers on both sides.
All these deaths, the end of the long Targaryen
dynasty just because Rhaegar thought Jon had
to be created, only for all of it, including
Jon's true heritage to not be important at
all at the end.
Jon killing the Night King would have justified
why Jon Snow was brought back to life.
It would have justified all the build-up to
this epic fight between the Night King and
Jon Snow
that’s been building for years.
All of that to be for nothing,
just because the showrunners David Benioff
and Dan Weiss decided it would be too obvious
for Jon to kill the Night King which was the
original plan and changed it to be Arya.
Don't be fooled by thinking Arya was planned
to kill the Night King all along,
and don't think it was foreshadowed to happen
way back in season 3 when Melisandre made
a prophecy to her about shutting the blue
eyes among the others, that she would repeat
to her in season 8 before she kills the Night
King.
That Arya-Melisandre scene where Melisandre
reminds her of the eyes she would shut forever,
and how the blue eyes are the only left from
the prophecy, well it wasn’t foreshadowing
anything.
Yes, Arya did kill the Night King who has
blue eyes, but at the time Melisandre first
made this prophecy to Arya, as I already mentioned,
it was back in season 3, in 2013.
Do you know when the showrunners decided it
would be Arya who kills the Night King?
In 2016!
After season 8 episode 3, the battle for Winterfell
aired,
the showrunners revealed that they made a
decision 3 years ago
that it would be Arya to kill the leader of
the White Walkers.
This was in 2019 which means David Benioff
and Dan Weiss decided around 2016,
after season 6 was made that it would be Arya
who kills the Night King.
This confirms Melisandre’s prophecy had
nothing to do with the Night King
as this scene took place in 2013 and it was
3 years after this scene
that the showrunners switched from Jon to
Arya to kill the Night King.
Arya’s whole story was about vengeance,
and her years of training with the Faceless
Men were justified when she avenged the killing
of her family when she avenged the Red Wedding
by using faces to kill Walder Frey.
She could have also used those faces to kill
Cersei, and once again avenge her family.
That was her story, not the White Walkers
and not the Night King.
They were Jon Snow’s story since Season
1.
Arya killing the Night King makes as much
sense as if Jon Snow ended up killing Walder
Frey or Cersei because that simply isn’t
what his story was built up to.
When the word of his father’s Ned Stark’s
fate reaches the Wall,
Jon initially wants to ride south and join
Robb in vengeance for his father,
but he doesn’t because Lord Commander Jeor
Mormont convinces him that those wars and
the game of thrones are not important
because there is only one war that matters
and it’s against the White Walkers.
Arya did not have anything to do with the
White Walker story,
she didn’t know they existed until the very
final season
while Jon’s whole story on the other hand
was about the White Walkers and the great
war that was coming.
In season 1 episode 1 Jon Snow is with his
father when a deserter of the Night's Watch
is brought before Ned to be executed.
That deserter named Will who ran away after
seeing the White Walkers kill his fellow brothers
of the Night's Watch, tells them what he saw,
the White Walkers.
Ned executes him because that is the law for
abandoning the Night's Watch.
So Jon is involved in the whole story since
the very beginning.
During season 1, he's a man to kill the first
wight in a thousands of years
when the corpse brought back to the Wall becomes
wight and attacks Lord Commander Mormont.
Jon saves Mormont's life by burning a wight,
earning a pardon for his earlier misdemeanor
as well as Valyrian steel sword Longclaw.
In season 2 Jon's story continues to be about
the threat beyond the Wall
as they ride north of the wall seeking for
Benjen and an explanation for the wight attack.
Jon sees Craster carrying a newborn into the
woods, leaving the child for a White Walker
as a sacrifice.
In season 3, Jon and the Free Folk arrive
at the Fist of the First Men,
only to survey the bloody aftermath of the
assault on the Night's Watch by the White
Walkers
and their army of wights.
In season 4, Jon takes a little break from
the White Walker story due to the threat of
the wildlings, but he's still very much aware
that they are out there,
advising Stannis to burn the bodies of the
dead wildlings in order to prevent them from
returning as wights.
In season 5, the White Walker story gets him
killed.
Jon makes a hard choice and does what he believes
is the best
and that is rescuing the Free Folk from Hardhome
and allowing them to pass the Wall
and settle in the North to keep them from
falling into the hands of the coming White
Walker army
as he knows that if they stay out there, they
would be killed, then resurrected
and added to the ever-growing army of the
undead.
While doing so, Hardhome is attacked by the
Night King's army
and Jon fights the White Walker and kills
him with Longclaw.
The Night King watches Jon intensely with
interest from a distance.
The Night King and Jon share a long glance
with each other
as the Night King uses his magic to raise
all of the dead as wights before Jon's eyes.
Still, Jon saved some of the Free Folk from
dying and joining the White Walker army
and allowed them to go south of the Wall,
which got him killed.
In season 6 Jon is resurrected by Melisandre
and the Lord of Light
because he still has a role to play in the
great war.
In the aftermath of his victory at Winterfell
and the confirmation from the Citadel that
winter has come,
Jon Snow warns the gathered lords of the North
and the Vale who wish to return home that
the war is not over, alluding at the coming
of the Night King.
In season 7 Jon prepares the North for the
upcoming great war against the White Walkers.
Upon receiving 2 letters, one an invitation
from Tyrion to come and meet Daenerys at Dragonstone,
and the second from Sam informing him of his
discovery of dragon glass on Dragonstone,
Jon decides to go to Dragonstone, risk his
life because that's the only chance for the
North to win this war.
Jon leads a mission to capture a wight and
prove to Cersei that the threat is real
in hopes to put a stop on fighting among the
living and get the support of the Lannister
army as well.
Jon fights a White Walker again, kills a bunch
of wights, and once again shares a glance
with the Night King.
Not once, but 2 times.
As you can see, the White Walkers were the
core of Jon's story, they were his purpose
and his destiny.
And few days ago it’s confirmed that Jon
Snow was originally supposed to be the one
to kill the Night King, as it's revealed Kit
said they told him in season 3 it would be
his character Jon Snow killing the Night King
which makes complete sense.
The Night King’s actor was changed because
they planned to have the Night King vs Jon
Snow epic fight where Jon Snow prevails, hence
why they switched from an actual actor playing
the Night King
to one of the world's best swordsman and 33
years experienced stunt man.
All of this buildup for years and years was
destroyed when in 2016 after the release of
season 6,
the showrunners decided that they left way
too many clues of Jon being the one to kill
the Night King, and instead of giving us a
satisfying conclusion to Jon's story and have
him kill the Night King,
the showrunners changed it to Arya and went
for a shock value instead.
Their explanation on why they decided for
it to be Arya who kills the Night King,
instead of Jon who's entire story from season
1 -- up until season 8 was building for this
great showdown between him and the Night King,
which was supposed to fulfill his destiny,
wrap up his story perfectly:
Benioff said “we hoped to kind of avoid
the expected, and Jon Snow has always been
the hero,
the one who’s been the savior, but it just
didn’t seem right to us, for this moment.”
Jon was literally made for this moment -- while
its Arya's first time seeing White Walkers
and wights and the Night King.
You can't make all that build up and throw
it away
just because you want to avoid the expected.
Good writing should be more valued than the
shock value.
I'm going to leave the last words to none
other than George RR Martin
who perfectly explained why changing the story
plot just because people expect it's not a
good choice as it takes away the satisfaction
of the build-up,
makes all the planted clues and foreshadows
a dead end and ultimately ruins everything:
Thank you
guys so much for watching, I hope you enjoyed
this video
and if you did please give it a big thumbs
up and I hope to see you in the next one!
Peace